if you don't already think Jenna Ortega
is the best Wednesday Addams get ready
because I'm about to convince you
otherwise she was literally Tim Burton's
hand-picked Choice she gave so much of
herself to the character and she's taken
some major Reigns on season two's
narrative first off Jenna Ortega carried
Wednesday through an entire season of a
TV show with another season on the way
as much as I love the other versions of
Wednesday that were played throughout
the years those characters weren't
developed enough to do that of course
the role was written to do so but Jenna
had a lot of impact on the lines that
Wednesday said and her motivations she
was adamant about not creating a love
triangle for Wednesday as she thought
that wouldn't ring true to her character
she also refused to say certain lines as
she thought they frankly just weren't
good enough when Tim Burton and the rest
of the production team landed on Jenna
it was like a casting light bulb went
off and when we found Jenna it was just
like she was the one it was also clear
that she was truly dedicated to the role
from day one I honestly was so nervous
to do this part because I just want to
do her justice she learned how to fence
to play the cello she learned German and
even dyed her own hair to make it look
more realistic I would walk like
Wednesday and I think that people
thought I might have been kind of crazy
another thing I can't help but mention
it's the fact that Jenna Ortega has
always been compared to the OG Wednesday
her entire life she watched all the
movies when she was younger and her
sense of humor is very fitting to the
iconic character she inherently has a
dry sense of humor as Jenna and so she's
Incorporated that into Wednesday Tim
Burton compares her to a silent movie
actor she's easily able to convey things
Without Words which is Peak Wednesday
Behavior we were very lucky to have
Jenna because I can't imagine any other
Wednesday a fun little anecdote about
Jenna playing Wednesday is that her
closet seemed to lose all of its color
after she started playing the role it's
just another example of how she fully
embraced the character she put a lot of
herself into Wednesday and it seemed
like Wednesday return to the favor when
it came to Jenna's wardrobe another fun
fact about Wednesday's quirks she
literally never blinked during the show
I'm hoping she had some eye drops in her
Pockets or something because you can
truly count on one hand the amount of
times you see Wednesday's eyes close and
let's be real Jenna Ortega is taking
over the horror scene from TY West's ex
The Babysitter 2 and of course Scream 5
and 6. Jenna does not shy away from Gore
even during her first meeting with Tim
Burton she had fake blood on her face
because she was shooting X at the time
in her opinion Wednesday could be a lot
darker and delve deeper into the horror
genre she's hoping to bring that forward
comes season two I think we want to up
kind of the horror aspect a little bit
and then get Wednesday out of the
Romantic situation I personally think
Wednesday would approve of that decision
now do I really need to say more about
this I'm only going on for the sake of
explanation but honestly you should know
where I'm going with this Janna wanted
to put a lot of herself into the
physical aspects of this role hence the
reason why she learned fencing in cello
another thing she wanted to do was
choreograph Wednesday's dance scene even
though she really hadn't slept in like
two days and was sick with kovid like
she did a ton of research into the 80s
golf club scene Lena Lovich and Susie
and the Banshees among others she even
did a little callback to Lisa loring's
original Wednesday Adams dance move the
reason why this is important is because
Jenna would not consider herself a
dancer or a choreographer but created a
dance that put the entire internet in a
Chokehold I can't imagine anyone else
would be able to do this as Wednesday
Adams professional dancer or not okay I
had to be a little cheeky and throw this
in here when Jenna Ortega was 14 she
starred in a Disney show called Stuck in
the Middle about a family with seven
children the show ran for three seasons
with the final episode airing sometime
in 2018. Jenna's character was named
Harley she was the middle child if my
family was a week I'd be Wednesday come
on it's like it was meant to happen Okay
so if I can't convince you that Jenna
Ortega was the best possible choice for
Wednesday's teen years I recommend you
watch this video again backed by Tim
Burton compared to the characters her
entire life and literally predicted by
Disney Channel don't come for me on this
what's your favorite thing about Jenna
Ortega's Wednesday